This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. One, two, three! One, two, three! From Birmingham, Alabama to Washington, D.C., all across the country, old Confederate monuments are coming down. Many monuments to Confederate soldiers and slaveholders are being taken down either by protesters or by local officials. In Raleigh, North Carolina, Juneteenth demonstrators tore down two statues from a monument outside the Capitol building. In Richmond, Virginia, protesters toppled statues of Confederate leaders William Carter Wickham and Jefferson Davis.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。一，二，三！一，二，三！从阿拉巴马州的伯明翰到华盛顿特区，全美各地都在拆除历史悠久的邦联纪念碑。许多纪念邦联士兵和奴隶主的纪念碑正被抗议者或地方官员拆除。在北卡罗来纳州罗利市，六月节（Juneteenth）的示威者推倒了国会大厦外纪念碑上的两座雕像。在弗吉尼亚州里士满，抗议者推倒了邦联领导人威廉·卡特·威克姆和杰斐逊·戴维斯的雕像。
Carter Wickham and Jefferson Davis. And Virginia Governor Ralph Northam ordered the removal of a statue of Confederate General Robert E. Lee. Yes, that statue has been there for a long time, but it was wrong then and it is wrong now. And it isn't just monuments to the Confederacy. Over 20 statues of Christopher Columbus have come down across the country, too, in cities like Providence, Rhode Island, Minneapolis, Minnesota, and even Columbus, Ohio. The Christopher Columbus statue, it is down. It's the latest form of protest against racial injustice. People across the country... These monuments have been falling in the middle of historic protests against police brutality.
卡特·威克姆和杰斐逊·戴维斯。弗吉尼亚州长拉尔夫·诺瑟姆下令移除邦联将军罗伯特·E·李的雕像。是的，那座雕像在那里立了很久，但过去是错的，现在依然是错的。不仅是邦联纪念碑。全美各地还有20多座克里斯托弗·哥伦布的雕像被推倒，城市包括罗德岛州普罗维登斯、明尼苏达州明尼阿波利斯，甚至还有俄亥俄州哥伦布市。克里斯托弗·哥伦布的雕像被推倒了。这是反对种族不公的最新抗议形式。全国各地的人们……这些纪念碑在抗议警察暴力的历史性浪潮中纷纷倒塌。
Sparked by the murder of George Floyd in Minneapolis, these demonstrations have spread to communities big and small across the country and around the world. And as they've grown, the protests have become about much more than police violence. This national uprising has inspired a massive reckoning with our country's past. Suddenly, decades of inertia and foot-dragging have given way to decisive action. A few years back, we did a story about a couple of controversial monuments in New Mexico. They honored a Spanish conquistador named Juan de Añate, who was an early settler in the region. And yes, those statues have been back in the news recently, too. So we wanted to check in with Stan Alcorn, the reporter who did that original story for us.
在明尼阿波利斯乔治·弗洛伊德遇害事件的引发下，这些游行示威活动已经蔓延到全美乃至世界各地的大大小小社区。随着规模不断扩大，抗议活动的诉求早已超越了警察暴力本身。这场全国性的抗议激发了人们对国家历史的巨大反思。突然之间，几十年的因循守旧和拖延让位给了果断的行动。几年前，我们做过一篇关于新墨西哥州几座有争议的纪念碑的报道。它们是为了纪念一位名叫胡安·德·奥尼亚特（Juan de Oñate）的西班牙征服者，他是该地区的早期定居者。是的，这些雕像最近又上了新闻。因此，我们想联系斯坦·奥尔科恩（Stan Alcorn），他是当初为我们做这篇报道的记者。
Hey, Stan. Hey, Roman. So tell us about the protest that happened a couple of weeks ago in Albuquerque. Yeah, so on Monday, June 15th, I was sitting at my desk following this all just through videos on Twitter and live streams. And it was this scene very much like the ones we've seen play out across the country with Confederate generals and with Christopher Columbus of activists actively trying to pull down this statue of Oñate, really just with a rope around it, with a pickaxe. And at the same time, people trying to prevent them from doing it,
嘿，斯坦。嘿，罗曼。给我们讲讲几周前在阿尔伯克基发生的抗议活动吧。好的，6月15日星期一，我坐在办公桌前，通过推特上的视频和直播关注着这一切。这个场景和我们在全国各地看到的、针对邦联将军和克里斯托弗·哥伦布的抗议活动非常相似：激进分子极力试图拉倒这座奥尼亚特雕像，他们用绳子套住它，用镐去凿。与此同时，另一些人在极力阻止他们这样做，
people who were heavily armed, people who looked like members of a militia in camouflage. So it was this really tense scene that I was seeing, and pretty quickly the thing that you might be afraid would happen in that kind of scene occurred. There were gunshots. you might be afraid would happen in that kind of scene occurred. There were gunshots.
那些全副武装的人，那些看起来像穿着迷彩服的民兵成员的人。我看到的场景非常紧张，很快，你可能担心在那种场景下发生的事情就发生了。有枪声响起。你可能担心在那种场景下发生的事情就发生了。有枪声响起。
And it was clear that somebody had been shot. And suddenly it became a very different kind of story. And what was this like for you watching this all unfold? You know, it was a really strange experience. These are statues that I have known my entire life, basically. I mean, I grew up in Albuquerque. I was following as this statue was put up. And now I'm like seeing people try to pull them down. And not only that, as an investigative reporter at Reveal, one of the things that I cover often is right-wing extremism. And I was actually finishing up a story about right-wing extremists.
很明显有人中枪了。突然之间，这变成了一个截然不同的故事。你当时看着这一切上演，是什么感受？你知道，那是一种非常奇怪的体验。基本上，这些雕像是伴随我一生长大的。我是说，我在阿尔伯克基长大。我曾关注过这座雕像的竖立。现在我却看到人们试图推倒它们。不仅如此，作为 Reveal 栏目的调查记者，我经常报道的一个领域是右翼极端主义。当时我实际上正在完成一篇关于右翼极端分子的报道。
And it was as if with these militia members, with the kind of things that they believe, with the threatened use of violence, it was like people from my Reveal extremism story had suddenly walked into my childhood public art story. So, it was this really strange kind of collision of worlds. Yeah. It seems like a lot of our history is all colliding at this very moment where we're reconciling with huge stories of our past and present. It's really something to witness. So, we're going to go back to that protest and the shooting and everything that happened in the last couple of weeks. But first, we wanted to replay Stan's original story, which looks at the history of Oñate's arrival in New Mexico and the enormous battle over these monuments, which started back in the 1990s. Check it out.
就好像这些民兵成员、他们的信仰以及对暴力的威胁，让我在 Reveal 极端主义报道里遇到的人，突然闯入了我的童年公共艺术报道中。所以，这是两个世界非常奇怪的交汇。是的。在我们重新审视过去和现在的重大历史事件的当下，感觉我们的许多历史都在这一刻交汇了。亲眼目睹这一切真的很有感触。因此，我们将回到那场抗议、枪击事件以及过去几周发生的一切。但首先，我们想重播斯坦最初的报道，该报道回顾了奥尼亚特抵达新墨西哥州的历史，以及始于20世纪90年代围绕这些纪念碑的巨大争论。一起来听听吧。
On January 7, 1998, an envelope landed on the desk of Larry Calloway. He was a columnist with the Albuquerque Journal. It was sort of a combination of a press release and a ransom note and a photo. A photo. The photo was a Polaroid of a cut-off riding boot with a huge Spanish spur, all in bronze. And I read the note. The note hinted that the bronze foot came from a statue of a man named Juan de Oñate seated on a horse. It was part of a monument on the side of a rural highway near where Oñate founded the first Spanish colony in New Mexico back in 1598. Larry figured this was probably a hoax. This is Stan Alcorn, a reporter with the investigative podcast Reveal.
1998年1月7日，拉里·卡洛韦（Larry Calloway）的桌上多了一个信封。他是《阿尔伯克基日报》的专栏作家。那有点像是新闻稿、勒索信和一张照片的结合体。一张照片。照片是一张宝丽来的拍立得，上面是一只被割下来的骑马靴，配有巨大的西班牙马刺，全是青铜材质。我读了便条。便条暗示这只青铜脚来自一尊骑在马上的男子雕像，他叫胡安·德·奥尼亚特。它是新墨西哥州一条乡村公路旁的一座纪念碑的一部分，奥尼亚特就是1598年在附近建立了新墨西哥州第一个西班牙殖民地。拉里觉得这可能是一个恶作剧。这是斯坦·奥尔科恩，调查类播客 Reveal 的记者。
There are collaborators on the story today. So he handed the tip off to the newsroom, and a reporter called up the visitor center at the Oñate Monument. And asked, is your statue missing a right foot? And the guy said, what? And he went out and checked, came back, and he was, you know, in shock. He said, it's gone. Oñate is one of the world's lesser-known conquistadors, but his name is all over New Mexico. There are Oñate streets, Oñate schools. For decades, there was an annual fiesta where one lucky guy would get to be Oñate,
今天这个故事还有其他合作者。所以他把这条线索交给了新闻编辑室，一名记者打电话给奥尼亚特纪念碑的游客中心。并问道，你们的雕像少了一只右脚吗？那个人说，什么？然后他出去查看，回来时，你知道，整个人都惊呆了。他说，不见了。奥尼亚特是世界上不太知名的征服者之一，但他的名字在新墨西哥州随处可见。这里有奥尼亚特街，奥尼亚特学校。几十年来，这里每年都会举办节日，其中一个幸运的家伙可以扮演奥尼亚特，
complete with a cape and helmet. There's even a song. Viva Oñate! Viva! Viva Oñate! Viva! Viva la historia de este gran señor! In parts of New Mexico, he's treated as a kind of founding father. But history is not all song and dance and wearing capes. He was a conquistador, after all. The envelope Larry got also included an excerpt from a history book on Oñate's treatment of New Mexico's native
身披披风，头戴头盔。甚至还有一首歌。奥尼亚特万岁！万岁！奥尼亚特万岁！万岁！伟大领主的历史万岁！在新墨西哥州的部分地区，他被当作一种开国元勋来对待。但历史并不全是歌舞和披风。毕竟，他是一个征服者。拉里收到的信封里还包含了一段历史书的摘录，讲述了奥尼亚特如何对待新墨西哥州的当地
people. It described an incident that ended with Oñate sentencing a group of men from Acoma Pueblo to each have one foot chopped off. If the symbolism of removing the statue's foot was unclear, the note made it explicit. It said, we took the liberty of removing Oñate's right foot on behalf of our brothers and sisters at Acoma Pueblo. We will be melting this foot down and casting small medallions to be sold to those who are historically ignorant. The statue's sculptor cast a new right foot and reattached it. The medallions never turned up. But the story stuck. It got picked up by NPR and the New York Times.
原住民。其中描述了一起事件，结局是奥尼亚特判处阿科玛普韦布洛（Acoma Pueblo）的一群男子每人被砍掉一只脚。如果移除雕像一只脚的象征意义还不明确的话，便条将其表述得淋漓尽致。上面写着：“我们斗胆代表阿科玛普韦布洛的兄弟姐妹们移除了奥尼亚特的右脚。我们将把这只脚熔化，铸成小型奖章，出售给那些历史盲。”雕塑家为雕像铸造了一只新的右脚并重新接上。那些奖章从未出现过。但这个故事流传了下来。它被全国公共广播电台（NPR）和《纽约时报》报道了。
I was a seventh grader in Albuquerque at the time. And what I remember is how the subject I found most boring, history, was suddenly this exciting mystery that remains unsolved to this day. Who stole Oñate's foot? And then there was the timing. 1998 was the 400th anniversary of Oñate's arrival. There were corto centenario celebrations planned all over the state. There would be theater, parades, a commemorative stamp. In a second note to the paper, the so-called Friends of Acoma wrote, we see no glory in celebrating Oñate's fourth centennial, and we do not want our faces rubbed in it. In other words, the point of cutting off the statue's foot was to spoil the party.
那时我是阿尔伯克基的一名七年级学生。我记得的是，我曾经觉得最无聊的科目——历史，突然变成了一个惊心动魄的谜团，至今仍未解开。是谁偷走了奥尼亚特的脚？然后还有时间点。1998年是奥尼亚特抵达400周年。全州上下都计划举行四百周年纪念活动。会有戏剧、游行、纪念邮票。在给报社的第二封信中，所谓“阿科玛之友”写道：“我们认为庆祝奥尼亚特四百周年没有任何荣耀可言，我们也不想把脸凑上去让他们羞辱。”换句话说，砍掉雕像脚的意义就是要搅黄这场派对。
And the centerpiece of that party that got a mention in all the foot-cutting stories was a cuarto centenario memorial being planned for Albuquerque's historic center. The proposal? Another bronze statue of Juan de Oñate. This one right in the middle of New Mexico's biggest city. But with all this new attention on Oñate, the second statue wasn't going to get built without a fight. I still didn't see the storm that was coming. It was still in its infancy.
而那场派对的核心是在阿尔伯克基历史中心规划的四百周年纪念碑，它在所有关于砍脚的故事中都被提及。提案是什么？又是一座胡安·德·奥尼亚特的青铜雕像。这座雕像就立在新墨西哥州最大城市的正中心。但随着对奥尼亚特的新关注，第二座雕像若想建成势必免不了一场恶战。我当时仍然没有预见到即将到来的风暴。它还处于萌芽状态。
Conchita Lucero was one of the organizers of the 400th anniversary celebrations in Albuquerque and one of the most passionate advocates for a new Oñate statue. A passion that goes back to her childhood, growing up in 1950s New Mexico, knowing almost nothing about Oñate, or the state's two centuries as a Spanish colony.
康奇塔·露西罗（Conchita Lucero）是阿尔伯克基400周年庆祝活动的组织者之一，也是新奥尼亚特雕像最热情的倡导者之一。这种热情可以追溯到她的童年，她在20世纪50年代的新墨西哥州长大，对奥尼亚特或该州作为西班牙殖民地的两个世纪历史几乎一无所知。
When I was a child, at 10 years of age, I asked my grandmother, who was a school teacher, I was reading the American history books, I said, didn't our people do anything? You know, that's how I felt. She didn't know New Mexico history. All Conchita knew was that her Spanish ancestors had come to the state centuries before the Anglo classmates who called people like her dirty Mexicans or the Anglo teachers who kept her out of a leadership club.
当我还是个10岁的孩子时，我问我的祖母，她是一名学校老师，当时我正在读美国历史书，我说：“我们的人民难道什么都没做吗？”你知道，我当时就是这种感觉。她不懂新墨西哥州的历史。康奇塔只知道，她的西班牙祖先来到该州的时间，比那些称她这样的人为“肮脏的墨西哥人”的盎格鲁同班同学，或者把她拒之领导力俱乐部之外的盎格鲁老师要早几个世纪。
And she knew that racism and ignorance of history were somehow connected. If we make you feel like the underdog, and then we take away your history and take away your knowledge, you're starting from scratch. Conversations, you don't know how to even participate. You just let the other guy put you down. participate. You just let the other guy put you down. Conchita thought if she could just search out her own European roots, it would help her fight back. None of this is uncommon in New Mexico, where people have been reaching back to their colonial roots and identifying as Spanish since the 1800s. After Conchita retired, she found a lot of like minds in local genealogical and historical societies.
她知道种族主义和对历史的无知在某种程度上是有联系的。如果我们让你觉得自己像个失败者，然后我们剥夺你的历史和知识，那你就是白手起家。进行对话时，你甚至不知道该如何参与。你只能任由对方贬低你。参与。你只能任由对方贬低你。康奇塔认为，如果她能去探寻自己的欧洲之根，就能帮助自己进行反击。在新墨西哥州，这并不是什么罕见的事，这里的人们自19世纪以来就一直在追溯他们的殖民根源，并将自己认同为西班牙人。康奇塔退休后，在当地的家谱和历史协会里找到了许多志同道合的人。
She learned how to use birth and death and baptism records to trace her family tree. There was the occasional Native American ancestor, but she was most excited to find branches like the one that extended back to a Spanish captain who brought his wife and kids through the Chihuahuan desert on Oñate's 1598 expedition. She saw them as having transformed the region by bringing livestock and Catholicism and the Spanish language. You'd start finding your family members and you're going, wow, I never knew they did all of this. Did it change how you saw yourself? all of this. Did it change how you saw yourself? Yes. I never argued that one person wasn't as good as the other, but sometimes you were made to feel inferior. And at that point, that inferiority
她学会了如何利用出生、死亡和洗礼记录来追溯她的家谱。偶尔会有美洲原住民祖先，但最让她兴奋的是找到了那些可以追溯到一个西班牙船长的分支，他在1598年奥尼亚特的远征中带着妻子和孩子穿过了奇瓦瓦沙漠。在她看来，他们通过带来牲畜、天主教和西班牙语改变了该地区。你会开始寻找你的家庭成员，然后你会感叹：“哇，我从来不知道他们做过这一切。”这改变了你对自己的看法吗？这一切。这改变了你对自己的看法吗？是的。我从未争辩过一个人不如另个人，但有时你会感到自卑。而到了那个时候，那种自卑
left. And so it was that Conchita was on the Quarto Centenario committee when they met with the Albuquerque Arts Board to discuss their request for a prominent new statue of Juan de Oñate, the man they called the father of the Hispanic culture and our state. And who the Friends of Acoma accused of destroying Native people's way of life. Was what happened at Acoma brought up? No. And was it on your mind? brought up? No. And was it on your mind? No. Was it something that you knew about? I wasn't as versed in it as I have become. For people who don't know Akuma, what is that? This is Alida, or Tweedy Swazo, an Akuma woman who would become an outspoken opponent of an Oñate statue in Albuquerque. Acoma is the oldest continuously inhabited community in the United States.
就消失了。因此，当四百周年纪念委员会与阿尔伯克基艺术委员会开会讨论他们关于为胡安·德·奥尼亚特竖立一座醒目新雕像的请求时，康奇塔也在场，他们称奥尼亚特为“西班牙文化和我们州的之父”。而阿科玛之友则指责他摧毁了原住民的生活方式。阿科玛发生的事情被提出来讨论了吗？没有。这在你的脑海里吗？提出来了吗？没有。这在你的脑海里吗？没有。这是你了解的事情吗？我当时对它的了解没有后来那么深。对于不了解阿科玛的人来说，那是什么地方？这是阿利达，或称特威迪·斯瓦佐（Tweedy Swazo），她是一位阿科玛女性，后来成为阿尔伯克基奥尼亚特雕像公开的反对者。阿科玛是美国最古老的持续有人居住的社区。
And it sits on a mesa 375 feet above the valley below. She actually carries a postcard of Acoma to show people when she travels. It's a village built on top of a mesa, which if you're not from the desert, it's like a huge rock pedestal. And that mesa just towers over the flat, empty plain below. All of it a hundred shades of brown, from light tan to deep rust. It's incredible. The tough thing with radio is you don't have pictures. Like, how to help people visualize it.
它坐落在一个高出下方山谷375英尺的平顶山（mesa）上。她旅行时甚至随身携带一张阿科玛的明信片用来展示给别人看。那是一个建在平顶山顶上的村庄，如果你不是来自沙漠，它就像一个巨大的岩石底座。平顶山高高耸立在下方平坦空旷的平原之上。全都是一百种不同深浅的棕色，从浅棕褐到深铁锈色。这太不可思议了。做广播节目最难的一点就是没有图片。比如，如何帮助人们去想象它。
Because it's like no other place on earth. No, it's not. It's beautiful. it because it's like no other place on earth. No, it's not. It's beautiful. It's desert and rocks and sandstone and that's where I come from, you know. And unlike the dozens of pueblos that disappeared after the arrival of the Spanish, Acoma is still here. Each year, tens of thousands of tourists drive an hour west of Albuquerque and then take a tour bus up a steep road to the top of the mesa. So just watch yourself. Don't get too close to the edge.
因为它不像地球上的任何其他地方。不，它不是。它很美。因为它不像地球上的任何其他地方。不，它不是。它很美。那是沙漠、岩石和砂岩，那就是我出身的地方，你知道的。与西班牙人到来后消失的几十个普韦布洛村庄不同，阿科玛至今犹存。每年有数万名游客驱车向西前往阿尔伯克基一小时车程的地方，然后乘坐旅游大巴沿着陡峭的道路开到平顶山顶。所以注意脚下。不要离边缘太近。
If you happen to fall over the edge, this is the end of your tour, and no refunds will be given, so just keep that in mind. On top, you can see buildings made of mud and sandstone that tour guides say date back to the 1100s. If you think about it, these houses have been passed down through the same family for almost a thousand years now. So now we're going to be walking past some of the older houses right up here, folks. All along the tour, there are tables where Acoma artists sell their wares, mostly pottery. But it's not just a tourist attraction. sell their wares, mostly pottery. These pots are made from the area here, about two miles.
如果你不小心摔下山崖，你的旅程就到此结束了，概不退款，所以请记住这一点。在山顶，你可以看到导游介绍说可以追溯到12世纪的泥土和砂岩建筑。如果你仔细想想，这些房子已经在同一个家族中代代相传了近千年。所以现在我们要走过一些更古老的房子，就在这上面，各位。一路上都有桌子，阿科玛的艺术家们在那里出售他们的商品，主要是陶器。但这不仅是一个旅游景点。出售他们的商品，主要是陶器。这些罐子是用当地的泥土制作的，大约两英里范围内。
But it's not just a tourist attraction. There are 15 families that live up top year-round, and hundreds more like Tweedy's, who go there for special occasions. Funerals, deaths, religious, fiestas, we were always there. What did you know about the history of your people in that place? That we came from the underworld on the back of Grandmother Spider. We wandered the earth. And when we got to where Akuma was, we were told this is where we're supposed to be. That's what I knew, you know, that we've been there forever. Tweedy also knew that when the Spanish arrived, they did terrible things to her ancestors.
但这不仅是一个旅游景点。全年都有15个家庭住在山顶，还有成百上千像特威迪那样的人，会在特殊场合去那里。葬礼、祭祀、宗教节日，我们总是在那里。关于你们的人民在那片土地上的历史，你知道些什么？我们是从地下世界骑着蜘蛛奶奶的背上来的。我们在大地上流浪。当我们到达阿科玛所在的地方时，我们被告知这就是我们应该呆的地方。这就是我所知道的，你知道的，我们已经在那里永远地生活下去了。特威迪还知道，当西班牙人到来时，他们对她的祖先做过可怕的事情。
But she didn't know the details. But she didn't know the details. Historians know many of those details today because they were written down by the Spanish in letters and legal documents. These documents, to quote Oñate's best-known biographer, skim the surface of events and sometimes present Oñate, quote, as he wished to be seen, not as things actually were. Which makes their description of what happened at Acoma all the more shocking. After 13 of Oñate's men came looking for food and were killed, Oñate declared a war of blood and fire. In the most brutal account of the battle that followed, Oñate's soldiers killed hundreds of men, women, and children, stabbed prisoners and threw them off the mesa,
但她并不知道细节。但她并不知道细节。历史学家今天之所以知道许多这些细节，是因为它们被西班牙人写进了信件和法律文件中。引用奥尼亚特最著名的传记作者的话，这些文件“掠过事件的表面，有时将奥尼亚特描绘成‘他希望被看待的样子，而不是事情原本的样子’。”这使得他们对阿科玛事件的描述更加令人震惊。在奥尼亚特的13名部下因寻找食物而被杀后，奥尼亚特宣称要进行一场血与火的战争。在随后最残酷的战役记录中，奥尼亚特的士兵杀害了数百名男人、妇女和儿童，用刺刀刺死囚犯并将他们从平顶山上扔下去，
and set fires that suffocated women and children who'd taken shelter in sacred rooms known as kivas. They then rounded up 500 prisoners and put them on trial. Oñate sentenced those over 12 years old to 20 years of slavery. Those under 12, he separated from their families, giving the girls to the church and the boys to the captain who just destroyed their village. And then there's the most infamous detail in a document signed by Oñate himself. It says, the males who are over 25 years of age, I sentence to have one foot cut off. His cruelty to the innocent of Acoma was one of the 12 crimes for which Añate himself would later be tried and convicted by the Spanish crown. As punishment, he would be banished permanently from the territories of New Mexico. This is the history that Tweedy and I and many
并放火烧死了那些在被称为 kivas 的神圣房间里避难的妇孺。随后他们搜捕了500名囚犯并对其进行审判。奥尼亚特判处12岁以上的人20年奴役。12岁以下的人则与家人骨肉分离，女孩交给了教会，男孩则交给了刚刚摧毁他们村庄的船长。然后是奥尼亚特本人签署的文件中最臭名昭著的细节。上面写道：“25岁以上的男性，我判处砍掉一只脚。”他对阿科玛无辜民众的残暴行径，是西班牙王室后来对奥尼亚特本人进行审判并定罪的12条罪状之一。作为惩罚，他被永久驱逐出新墨西哥州领土。随着偷脚事件在全州范围内激起回响，特威迪、我和许多
other New Mexicans were learning for the first time as news of the stolen foot ricocheted around the state. That was the beginning of it. That was everybody's first awareness. And at the same time, we were also learning that the city of Albuquerque was planning to build this new, much more prominent statue of Oñate. He had been cast out of New Mexico forever. been cast out of New Mexico forever. And now you want to bring him back and put him on a statue? It's still mind boggling. How Oñate went from a banished conquistador to a father of New Mexico that people wanted to put on a statue is a story for another podcast. But the simple answer is he was first. The first to build a European colony in the region, even if that colony was soon abandoned. He was among the first to bring wheat and sheep
其他新墨西哥州人第一次了解到了这段历史。那是这一切的开始。那是所有人的初次觉醒。与此同时，我们还得知阿尔伯克基市正计划建造这座全新的、更加显眼的奥尼亚特雕像。他已经被永久驱逐出新墨西哥州了。现在你们却想把他带回来为他树立雕像？这简直匪夷所思。奥尼亚特是如何从一个被流放的征服者变成一个人们想要为之树立雕像的新墨西哥州之父的，这是另一个播客的话题。但简而言之，他是第一人。他是第一个在该地区建立欧洲殖民地的人，尽管该殖民地很快就被废弃了。他是最早带来小麦、绵羊
and Catholicism. And because every people needs a founding figure, Spanish New Mexico made Juan de Oñate its George Washington, even if he had been cast out forever. But it did not take long for the Albuquerque Arts Board to realize that Juan de Oñate was not everyone's idea of a founding father. They could see that another triumphant statue of him on a horse would be a bad look for the city. So by the time the foot was cut off of the old statue on the side of the highway, they made a few changes to the plan. The memorial would need to depict not just
和天主教的人之一。由于每个人民都需要一个开国元勋，西班牙裔的新墨西哥州把胡安·德·奥尼亚特当作他们的乔治·华盛顿，尽管他已被永久流放。但阿尔伯克基艺术委员会没过多久就意识到，胡安·德·奥尼亚特并不是每个人心目中的开国元勋。他们明白，再为他竖立一座骑马的凯旋雕像对城市来说会是一个糟糕的形象。因此，当公路旁的旧雕像被砍掉一只脚时，他们对计划做了一些修改。纪念碑描绘的不仅要
Oñate, but also the peaceful settlers who came with him and the Native Americans who preceded and survived him. And the exact form the memorial would take would be up to a team of artists. They had a team of two, but right before the newspapers got wind of the missing foot, they decided to add a third. When Nora Naranjo-Morse got the call, she was in the place where she's most comfortable. Her studio. I mean, who would want to be here, right? In the studio with a fireplace in the rain. On the phone was the director of public art for the city of Albuquerque,
有奥尼亚特，还要有随他而来的和平定居者，以及在他之前和之后幸存下来的美洲原住民。纪念碑的确切形式将由一个艺术家团队决定。他们原本是一个二人团队，但在报纸风闻少了一只脚的消息之前，他们决定增加第三人。诺拉·纳兰霍-莫斯（Nora Naranjo-Morse）接到电话时，正身处她最舒适的地方——她的工作室。我是说，谁不想呆在这里呢？在下雨天带着壁炉的工作室里。电话那头是阿尔伯克基市公共艺术主管，
asking if she wanted to be part of a tricultural collaboration. It would be the Hispanic artist who had built the statue that had its foot stolen, an Anglo artist, and her, a Tewa Indian artist from the Santa Clara Pueblo. The call was so out of the blue. This was a public art project. I'd never done public art, really. This was with other people. I had been working solo, so I didn't really know. I was listening. And did you say yes right then, or do you remember how the phone called? I said yes. I said yes right away because I opened my mouth and I said yes. And then afterwards I thought, oh, I wonder what this is going to be like.
询问她是否愿意参与一个三元文化合作项目。成员将包括雕像被偷走了一只脚的那位西班牙裔艺术家、一位盎格鲁艺术家，以及她——一位来自圣克拉拉普韦布洛的特瓦族印第安艺术家。这通电话来得太突然了。这是一个公共艺术项目。我其实从未做过公共艺术。这是与其他人的合作。我一直是独立创作，所以其实我并不了解。我在听。你当时就答应了吗？还是你记得这通电话是怎么打的？我答应了。我立刻就答应了，因为我一张嘴就说了好。然后事后我想，哦，不知道这会是什么样子的。
She'd find out when she showed up for that first meeting. In an institutional room with fluorescent lighting and a chalkboard, the other artists wheeled in a model of a statue they'd already put together. It was another triumphant statue of Juan de Oñate on a horse. And that's when they begin to talk about the granite pedestal and how I could use it. The pedestal beneath Oñate's horse's feet. Right. I felt insulted. I felt hurt. I felt marginalized. I didn't think I could do that. Although in myself, I was thinking that there was a solution, that art could tell a story that was truthful.
当她出席第一次会议时，她就会知道了。在一个有着荧光灯和黑板的机构会议室里，其他艺术家推出了一个他们已经拼凑好的雕像模型。那是又一座骑在马上的胡安·德·奥尼亚特的凯旋雕像。然后他们开始谈论花岗岩基座以及我如何使用它。奥尼亚特马蹄底下的基座。没错。我感到被侮辱了。我感到受伤。我感到被边缘化。我觉得我做不到这一点。尽管我内心认为有一个解决方案，艺术可以讲述一个真实的故事。
Nora quite literally refused to put Oñate on a pedestal, and the artists went back to the drawing board. But now Nora was in the public eye, and soon she started getting calls from other Pueblo people who wanted her to leave the project entirely in protest. I didn't do that. And when I refused, I got some, I think people were disappointed. But I realized that by me staying in the game, I would at least be able to fight for that voice that I think was so important. Not just my artistic voice, but the voice of these people
诺拉字面意义上拒绝把奥尼亚特高高捧上基座，艺术家们不得不重新回到设计图纸前。但现在诺拉暴露在公众视线中，不久她开始接到其他普韦布洛人的电话，希望她为了抗议而彻底退出这个项目。我没有这么做。当我拒绝时，我得到了一些……我想人们是失望的。但我意识到，只要我留在局里，我至少能够为那个我认为如此重要的声音而战。不仅仅是我的艺术之声，还有这些经历了彻底改变他们文化的不可思议经历的人民的声音。
that had gone through this incredible experience that changed their culture completely. And I kept going back to those things. And I kept going back to those things. The year of the 400th anniversary, 1998, came and went, and there was still no plan for the memorial. But the city would not give up. All the attention had made the memorial a very public test of whether the state was the land of tricultural harmony that it claimed to be. And so every time the process hit an impasse,
我不断回想起那些事情。我不断回想起那些事情。400周年纪念的1998年转瞬即逝，纪念碑仍然没有规划。但这座城市没有放弃。所有的关注使这座纪念碑成为了一场公开测试，检验该州是否真的是它所宣称的三元文化和谐之地。因此，每当进程陷入僵局，
the city just threw more time and money at it, hiring mediators and forming committees. At one point, one of those committees came up with a plan that would have restarted the whole artistic process, a plan Conchita's side couldn't tolerate. It called for a memorial without Oñate. And would focus on coexistence of Hispanics and the indigenous.
这座城市就会投入更多的时间和金钱，聘请调解员并组建委员会。有一次，其中一个委员会提出了一项计划，将重启整个艺术创作过程，这是康奇塔一方无法容忍的计划。它呼吁建立一个没有奥尼亚特的纪念碑。并将重点放在西班牙裔和原住民的共存上。
Well, then we said it wasn't our celebration. You know, it's your celebration now, it's not ours. You know, you don't get invited to a wedding, you don't start telling the bride and the groom, you should have had it this way or that way, or and that's what it was. It was our celebration.
好吧，那我们当时就说这不是我们的庆祝活动。你知道的，现在是你们的庆祝活动，不是我们的。你知道的，你没有被邀请参加一场婚礼，然后你却开始对新郎新娘指手画脚说“你们应该这样办或那样办”，情况就是这样。这是我们的庆祝活动。
But it was your celebration with public money in a public space that's in a city that has people of all different backgrounds. The grant was for our celebration, not for the Acoma celebration or for anybody else's. not for the Acoma celebration or for anybody else's. As far as Conchita's group was concerned, the presence of Oñate was non-negotiable, which made it hard to negotiate. In the end, there simply was no single design that everyone could agree on. In fact, eventually the artists stopped talking to each other. Instead, they proposed a memorial made up of two separate artworks,
但这是你们用公共资金在公共空间里举办的庆祝活动，而这个城市拥有各种不同背景的人。这笔资助是给我们庆祝活动的，不是为了阿科玛庆祝活动，也不是为了其他任何人的。不是为了阿科玛庆祝活动，也不是为了其他任何人的。在康奇塔的群体看来，奥尼亚特的存在是不可商量的，这使得协商变得困难。最终，根本没有一个能让所有人都满意的单一设计。事实上，最终艺术家们停止了彼此交谈。相反，他们提议建造一个由两个独立艺术品组成的纪念碑，
a series of bronze statues of Spanish settlers, including Oñate in full armor, and Nora's response, an abstract land art installation made out of the desert itself. It had gone from a small bronze statue to a memorial that would take up most of a city block and cost over half a million dollars,
一系列西班牙定居者的青铜雕像，包括身穿全套盔甲的奥尼亚特，以及诺拉的回应——一个由沙漠本身构成的抽象大地艺术装置。它已经从一个小型青铜雕像变成了一个将占据大半个城市街区、耗资超过五十万美元的纪念碑，
requiring the city to issue special bonds. Now the question was, would the city approve it? Conchita and the pro-Oñate forces lobbied the city council, while Oñate opponents, like Tweedy, took their case to the people. You know, finding out, well, who's for us and who isn't, and how do we target the people in that area for them to call their councilmen. And that's the first time I'd ever done that, you know?
需要市政府发行特别债券。现在的问题是，市政府会批准吗？康奇塔和支持奥尼亚特的势力游说市议会，而像特威迪这样的反对奥尼亚特的人则将他们的诉求带给民众。你知道的，去弄清楚，谁支持我们，谁不支持我们，以及我们如何锁定该地区的人民，让他们给市议员打电话。这是我第一次做那样的争取的，你知道吗？
You were like becoming an activist for the first time? Yeah, I was. I'd never, I'd never done that. The statue and also a highway the city was trying to build through a national monument of ancient petroglyphs, was making first-time activists out of a lot of Pueblo people. It's the first time that we really rallied around something. Activists, artists, citizens, and city councilors were headed for a final showdown.
你就像是第一次成为激进主义者？是的，我是。我以前从未做过那样的事。这座雕像以及市政府试图在古代岩画国家纪念碑穿过的公路，正把许多普韦布洛人变成初出茅庐的激进主义者。这是我们第一次真正围绕某件事团结起来。激进主义者、艺术家、市民和市议员们正走向最终的对决。
This is GOV 14, and now from Government Center in downtown Albuquerque, the Albuquerque City Council. In a series of meetings, the City Council auditorium was divided, like a pep rally, or Congress. On one side was the pro-Oñate crowd, mostly Hispanic people around Conchita's age. On the other side was the anti-Oñate group. They tended to be younger and more diverse, Native Americans, but also Anglos and African Americans, and a lot of people who identified as Chicano or Mestizo, explicitly embracing their indigenous as well as European ancestry.
这是 GOV 14 频道，现在从市中心阿尔伯克基政府中心为您转播阿尔伯克基市议会。在一系列会议中，市议会礼堂分裂了，就像一场拉拉队集会或国会一样。一边是支持奥尼亚特的群众，大多是和康奇塔年龄相仿的西班牙裔人。另一边是反奥尼亚特群体。他们往往更年轻、更多元化，有美洲原住民，也有盎格鲁人和非裔美国人，还有许多自认为是奇卡诺（Chicano）或麦士蒂索（Mestizo）的人，他们明确拥抱自己的原住民以及欧洲血统。
The city council tried to give the two sides equal time to speak. And in hour after hour of public comment, they went back and forth. But not over the design of the memorial, really. They were fighting over something much bigger and much more personal. Their place in American history. Our colony was the first in what is today the United States of America. You can't pretend that we didn't come here 400 years ago. This is really a matter of denigrating the Hispanic people of New Mexico. Do I have to stop? Oh, no, no, no.
市议会试图给双方平等的发言时间。在长达数小时的公众评论中，双方展开了激烈的拉锯战。但实际上并不是在争论纪念碑的设计。他们是在为更大、更私人的事情而战。他们在美国历史上的地位。我们的殖民地是如今美利坚合众国境内的第一个殖民地。你不能假装我们400年前没有来到这里。这实际上是在贬低新墨西哥州的西班牙裔人民。我必须停下来吗？哦，不，不，不。
Have some courage and listen. First of all, soy Chicano. And unlike some Hispanics that are here in the audience, I didn't just get off the plane from Spain. Oñata does not represent the best of my culture. You are not representing me. And I just want to say that I'm sorry that you and a small group of Hispanics in this room
拿出一 点勇气来听着。首先，我是奇卡诺。和在座的一些西班牙裔不同，我不是刚从西班牙下飞机。奥尼亚特并不代表我文化的最好一面。你不能代表我。我只想说，我很遗憾你和这个房间里的一小撮西班牙裔
feel like they have to slam another people's culture in order to feel pride. There were dozens of speakers, but the leaders were women from Acoma, like Tweedy. I didn't know that the awful things that happened to my people happened to my people until this statue became an issue. I'm really tired of being used as tourists, and our wares are the only things that matter in this community.
觉得为了找到自豪感，就必须贬低另一个文化的尊严。发言者有数十人，但领导者是来自阿科玛的女性，比如特威迪。我不知道那些发生在我族人身上的可怕事情落在了我族人头上，直到这座雕像成为一个问题。我真的厌倦了被当作游客来看待，在这个社区里，只有我们的商品才重要。
I'm begging you don't do this to my people I'm begging you don't do this to my people don't hurt them this way it's not right thank you very much last speaker
我求求你们，不要对我的人民这样做，我求求你们，不要对我的人民这样做，不要这样伤害他们，这不对，非常感谢最后一位发言者
IL Sanchez Davis it seemed like most people were on Tweedy's side. But if the city voted against the memorial, it wouldn't just be saying no to this statue of Oñate and the settlers and to Nora's landscape art. It would be admitting that this whole very public process that had dragged on for more than two years had been a failure. The committees, the design iterations, the debate, all for nothing. So when it finally came time to vote, all those in favor please signify by saying aye. Aye. Those opposed, no. They voted seven to two to build the memorial. That motion passes. to build the memorial.
IL·桑切斯·戴维斯。似乎大多数人都站在特威迪这边。但如果市议会对纪念碑投反对票，它不仅是在对这座奥尼亚特和定居者的雕像以及诺拉的景观艺术说不。它还将承认，这个拖延了两年多的公开进程是一场彻底的失败。委员会、设计方案、辩论，全都付诸东流。因此，当最终投票表决时，请所有赞成的人说“赞成”以示同意。赞成。反对的人，说“不”。他们以七票对二票通过了建造纪念碑的决议。该动议通过。建造纪念碑。
That motion passes. After the vote, Conchita Lucero told a reporter, I think our kids will finally learn about their ancestors. Tweedy Suazo and other anti-Oñate activists formed a prayer circle in the city council chambers and wept. We worked so hard. And it just, just didn't matter. It didn't matter what we said. It didn't matter what we do.
该动议通过。投票结束后，康奇塔·露西罗对记者说：“我想我们的孩子终于会了解他们的祖先了。”特威迪·斯瓦佐和其他反奥尼亚特激进分子在市议会大厅里围成一个祈祷圈，失声痛哭。我们付出了那么多努力。而这根本……根本无足轻重。我们说了什么并不重要。我们做了什么并不重要。
It didn't matter that we educated. It just didn't matter. If it all happened again today, do you think it would happen the same way? What would be different? I think Pueblos are just a little bit more politically astute now. Tweedy thinks what they learned was that the right arguments aren't enough. You need the right decision makers. She's one of several anti-Oñate activists who went on to get involved in electoral politics.
我们进行了教育也无济于事。这根本无足轻重。如果这一切今天再次发生，你认为还会以同样的方式发生吗？会有什么不同？我认为普韦布洛人现在在政治上更加敏锐了。特威迪认为他们学到的教训是，正确的论据是不够的。你需要正确的决策者。她是多位转而涉足选举政治的反奥尼亚特激进分子之一。
She's now the chair of the Native American Democratic Caucus of New Mexico. And this last cycle, she helped raise money and get out the vote for Deb Haaland, one of the two Native American women who just became the first ever to be elected to Congress. first ever to be elected to Congress. Today, if you go visit the Finnish memorial, what you'll see isn't Oñate on a horse. It's a compromise. It's really two memorials crammed into one. The first you can grasp without even getting out of your car. It's more than two dozen life-sized bronze figures, men and women, oxen and sheep, trudging up a hill. Juan de Oñate is in front, on foot, no plaque with his name, and under the watchful eye of a security camera that may or may not be pointed at his feet.
她现在是新墨西哥州美洲原住民民主党核心小组的主席。在刚刚过去的这个选举周期，她协助筹集资金并为德布·哈兰德（Deb Haaland）拉票，后者是刚刚当选为国会议员的首批两名美洲原住民女性之一。首批当选为国会议员的女性。今天，如果你去参观这个芬兰纪念碑，你看到的不会是骑马的奥尼亚特。这是一个妥协。它实际上是将两座纪念碑硬挤成了一个。第一座纪念碑，你甚至不用下车就能理解。那是二十多尊真人大小的青铜人物，有男有女，还有牛和羊，正艰难地爬坡。胡安·德·奥尼亚特走在最前面，步行，没有写着他名字的牌匾，并在一个可能对准或没有对准他脚部的安全摄像头的注视下。
The second memorial, right next to it, looks from above like a huge dirt spiral. But from ground level, you really just have to experience it. It's a striking contrast to the kind of art that's really in your face and didactic and says, this is what I mean. I think that reflects Pueblo thinking. It's much more subtle. It doesn't articulate in the way we've become used to as, you know, civilized people, colonized people.
第二座纪念碑，就在它旁边，从高处看像一个巨大的泥土螺旋。但从地面水平看，你真的必须亲身体验它。这与那种劈头盖脸、充满说教意味、直接告诉你“这就是我的意思”的艺术形成了鲜明的对比。我认为这反映了普韦布洛人的思维方式。它要微妙得多。它并不是以我们作为文明人、被殖民者所习惯的方式来表达的。
When I met Nora Naranjo-Morse to get a tour, she'd just been picking up trash left inside her part of the memorial. She was holding a donut wrapper as we walked down a dirt path that spirals slowly downhill into the ground. The street disappears behind the berms of chamisas and junipers on our right and left, then the buildings, then Oñate himself, until finally at the center of the spiral, all you can see is the land and water trickling across a rock. And I like that very much because I think that's what it was like a long time ago.
当我遇到诺拉·纳兰霍-莫斯并请她带我参观时，她刚刚捡完纪念碑她那部分里面留下的垃圾。当我们走下一条缓慢螺旋向下延伸入地下的泥土小路时，她手里拿着一个甜甜圈包装纸。街道在我们右边和左边的金合欢属植物和刺柏矮林后消失了，然后是建筑物，然后是奥尼亚特本人，直到最后在螺旋的中心，你能看到的只有土地和在岩石上流淌的溪水。我非常喜欢这样，因为我认为很久以前就是这个样子的。
That's how I interpret the past. If you sit low to the ground, you can almost get a glimpse of a world before Oñate arrived. It's an escape. But it's also intended as a confrontation between two totally different worldviews. Because as you walk back out of the spiral... This is what you see. The telephone lines, the sculpture of Oñate coming here, looking north, the stoplight, it's all there.
这就是我解读历史的方式。如果你低头坐在地上，你几乎可以瞥见奥尼亚特到来之前的世界。这是一个逃离。但它也是为了成为两种完全不同的世界观之间的对撞。因为当你走出螺旋……这就是你看到的。电话线、朝着北方前行的奥尼亚特雕塑、红绿灯，全都在那里。
And so you see that in some ways when they came, they brought us great opportunity, but at such a high cost. The brutal colonization was forever affecting to us. And I think we should never forget that. She hopes her piece of the memorial will remind people of that. But honestly, not that many people come here. The memorial doesn't attract nearly as much attention as the conflict over the memorial did. I think that's why it's important stewardship, not only to pick up the trash, but also to keep that story alive.
因此你看到，在某些方面，当他们到来时，他们给我们带来了巨大的机遇，但代价也太高了。残酷的殖民化对我们产生了永远的影响。我认为我们永远不应该忘记这一点。她希望她那部分的纪念碑能提醒人们这一点。但说实话，来这里的人并不多。这座纪念碑并没有像关于它的冲突那样吸引那么多关注。我认为这就是为什么细心的守护如此重要，不仅要捡垃圾，还要让那个故事活下去。
Because there are going to be a lot more generations of people coming, wondering, what is this? And that's where our story was going to end, until last year, when an old mystery re-emerged. Remember that first statue we told you about, the one that got its foot stolen? Well, for almost two decades, the foot thieves had remained in the shadows, their identities unknown. And then one day, Chris Eyre, the director of Smoke Signals and Skins, possibly the best known Native American filmmaker, was at La Choza, this great little New Mexican restaurant in Santa Fe. I was sitting there eating a taco with my business partner and someone came up to me and said, I have a story to tell you as I'm eating my taco. And I said, Oh shit, not another story. And you know, I heard a few key words, but I wasn't listening that intently.
因为还会有更多世代的人来到这里，好奇地问：这是什么？我们的故事本该到此结束，直到去年，一个古老的谜团再次浮出水面。还记得我们告诉你的第一座雕像吗？就是脚被偷的那座？嗯，近二十年来，偷脚贼一直隐匿在暗处，身份不明。直到有一天，曾执导《烟雾信号》和《剥皮者》的知名美洲原住民电影制作人克里斯·埃尔（Chris Eyre），来到圣达菲一家很棒的新墨西哥小餐馆 La Choza。我正坐在那里和我的商业合伙人吃玉米卷，有人向我走来说：“我正吃着玉米卷，有个故事要告诉你。”我说：“哦，操，别又是哪个故事。”你知道的，我听到了一些关键词，但我并没有那么专心听。
And all of a sudden it dawned on me. I said, wait a minute. And I turned and I said, are you talking about what I think you're talking about? It was the guy who cut the foot off the first Oñate statue. Or at least he claimed to be a spokesman for the group who did the deed. And the truth of the matter is that I could never verify it other than I believed it in the end. that I could never verify it other than I believed it in the end. Chris believed the guy, in part because he was presented with a very solid piece of evidence. When Chris met him for a second time in a forest of piñon trees, he unwrapped a piece of black velvet to reveal something no one had seen for 20 years. years. Lo and behold, there appeared probably a 28-inch long bronze patinaed boot of a Spanish conquistador. And I said to myself, wow. Then I looked around and I said to myself, where the
突然之间，我恍然大悟。我说：“等一下。”我转过身说：“你在说我想的那件事吗？”那个人就是砍掉第一座奥尼亚特雕像的脚的那家伙。或者至少他声称自己是干这事的那个团体的发言人。事实是，除了最终我相信了它之外，我再也无法核实。除了最终我相信了它之外，我再也无法核实。克里斯相信了这家伙，部分原因是他看到了一个非常确凿的证据。当克里斯在皮尼翁松树林中第二次见到他时，他打开了一块黑丝绒，露出了一个20年来没人见过的东西。瞧，那里出现了一只大约28英寸长的西班牙征服者青铜铜绿长靴。我对自己说：“哇。”然后我环顾四周，对自己说：“哪里来的……”
hell am I and what the hell am I doing here? A few chunks of the foot had been shaved off, where they'd made a half-hearted attempt to follow through on those medallions for the historically ignorant. But otherwise, it was still intact and still had the power to grab people's attention. If Chris knows the identity of the foot thieves, he is not revealing it. But he did talk about their motivations. You know, the party involved is not speaking from an activist position and doesn't feel like an activist. This person feels like a historian. He wasn't trying to start a movement or affect policy, just to write what Oñate did to Acoma men in 1599 into the history of the colonization of New Mexico.
地狱啊，我到底是谁，我在这里干什么？这只脚的一些部分被削掉了一些，他们当时曾试图草率地给那些对历史一无所知的人留下这些奖章。但除此之外，它仍然完好无损，并且依然有吸引人们注意力的力量。如果克里斯知道脚的窃贼的身份，他没有透露。但他确实谈到了他们的动机。你知道，相关方并不是从活动家的角度发言，也不觉得自己像个活动家。这个人感觉像个历史学家。他并不是想发起一场运动或影响政策，只是想把奥纳特在1599年对阿科马男人所做的事情写进新墨西哥州殖民化的历史中。
That story still doesn't have a statue, and maybe it never will. But in the meantime, the friends of Acoma are holding on to Oñate's foot. Coming up after the break, we talk with Stan Alcorn about everything that's happened with the Oñate statues over the past couple of weeks. And it's been a lot. So stay with us. Okay, so we're back with reporter Stan Alcorn to talk more about what's been happening in New Mexico just in the past couple of weeks.
这个故事仍然没有雕像，也许永远都不会有。但与此同时，阿科马的朋友们正紧紧抓着奥纳特的脚不放。中场休息回来后，我们将与斯坦·阿尔科恩探讨过去几周有关奥纳特雕像发生的一切。事情确实很多。所以请继续关注我们。好的，我们回到了记者斯坦·阿尔科恩身边，来进一步讨论新墨西哥州在过去几周里发生的事情。
So, Stan, like you said in the beginning of the show here, that it was a really strange feeling to have spent so much time exploring the history of these monuments and then see them come up in the news again. So, when did you start hearing that there might be some new conflict around the statues? So, the weekend before the protest that we talked about initially is when my phone started ringing. Tweedy Suazo, who had been one of the people vocally opposing the statue in Albuquerque, called me up and told me I needed to look at the front page of the Albuquerque Journal because there was Oñate on the front page. There was a new effort, basically, to have it removed. And there were people who were saying they were going to oppose it in the courts. So she was emailing all the same people who opposed it back in the 90s,
那么，斯坦，正如你在节目开始时所说的那样，花那么多时间去探索这些纪念碑的历史，然后又看到它们再次登上新闻，这种感觉真的很奇怪。那么，你是什么时候开始听说这些雕像可能会引发一些新的冲突的呢？所以，在我们最初谈论的那场抗议活动之前的那个周末，我的电话开始响了。图迪·苏亚佐是阿尔伯克基公开反对这座雕像的人之一，她打电话给我，告诉我需要看看《阿尔伯克基期刊》的头版，因为头版上刊登了奥纳特。基本上有一项要求将其移除的新努力。并且有人说他们将诉诸法庭进行反对。所以她给所有在90年代反对过它的人发了电子邮件，
kind of getting geared up for yet another kind of like long bureaucratic fight to now finally remove Oñate. Right, where you go to city council meetings and you talk to historians and you bring all that stuff out. But that's not what happened. What happened next? Yeah, so instead of this really long slog, everything started to happen really quickly. really long slog, everything started to happen really quickly. So to back up, I mean, there are two statues, right? There's the original older Oñate on a horse up on the side of the road. With the foot cut off. Exactly. That had the foot cut off. And then there's the Albuquerque Compromise,
开始准备进行又一场漫长的官僚斗争，以便现在终于移除奥纳特。对吧，你去参加市议会会议，你与历史学家交谈，你把所有这些东西都拿出来。但事情并不是这样的。接下来发生了什么？是的，所以没有经历这场漫长的拉锯战，一切开始发生得非常快。没有经历这场漫长的拉锯战，一切开始发生得非常快。为了回顾一下，我的意思是，这里有两座雕像，对吧？路边有一个最初较老的骑马奥纳特雕像。脚被砍掉了。没错。那座雕像的脚被砍掉了。然后是阿尔伯克基妥协方案，
where Oñate is walking with all the settlers. And both of these statues, there's going to be significant protests on Monday. But I started hearing from activists earlier in the day that the county up in northern New Mexico might be actually removing the equestrian Oñate that had its foot cut off. Before people even got there. To stop them from tearing it down, they were going to take it down first. Is that the idea? That does seem to be the idea. There also was already this presence of this right-wing militia, the New Mexico Civil Guard, that has been showing up at Black Lives Matter protests in New Mexico, heavily armed. And so I think there was fear, both of the activists attempting to pull the statue down,
奥纳特正与所有定居者一起行走。这两座雕像将在周一迎来重大的抗议活动。但我早些时候从活动家那里听说，新墨西哥州北部的那个县实际上可能会拆除那个脚被砍掉的骑马奥纳特雕像。在人们到达之前。为了阻止他们拆除雕像，他们打算先把它拆下来。是这个主意吗？这似乎确实是这个主意。当时那里也已经存在这种右翼民兵组织，即新墨西哥州国民警卫队，他们一直带着重武器出现在新墨西哥州的“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动中。所以我认为人们既害怕活动家试图拉倒雕像，
but also of some kind of violent confrontation. Right. They were trying to make it a safer situation by not having this controversial figure at this moment. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. So did you actually see the northern New Mexico Añate get hauled away? Like, what was it like? Yeah. First, it was just like rumors. Maybe county workers are doing something. There are trucks there.
也害怕某种暴力冲突。没错。他们试图通过在这个时刻不让这个充满争议的人物出现，来让情况变得更安全。是的，这非常合理。那么你真的看到新墨西哥州北部的奥纳特被拖走了吗？那是什么样的情景？是的。一开始，这只是谣言。也许是县里的工人在做些什么。那里有卡车。
And then I got texted a live stream, a Facebook live stream by an activist. Here it comes. Here it comes. And I went to it and... is a bulldozer driving around. And eventually there's a moment where the bulldozer or whatever this heavy equipment is called gets its big shovel underneath and just lifts it up and drives it away. And did it seem like this was a joyous event? What was the tone of the people that were there? Yeah, so the tone was pretty joyful, I would say,
然后我收到了一位活动家发来的直播短信，一个Facebook直播。它来了。它来了。我点进去看……是一台推土机到处开。最后，有一个时刻，推土机或者这台重型设备的名字叫什么，把它的巨型铲子伸到底下，然后把它抬起来开走了。这看起来像是一场欢乐的活动吗？那里的人们的基调是什么？是的，所以基调相当欢乐，我会说，
from the people who were watching on the side of the road. But there weren't that many of them. You really got a better sense of the way people felt about this at the planned protest because it still occurred. Now it was no longer really a protest, though, because there was no statue on the pedestal. Right, it was like a party. Yeah, it was like a celebration and kind of like ritual, where it was largely organized by these
来自路边观看的人们。但人数并没有那么多。你在计划中的抗议活动中确实能更好地感受到人们的真实感受，因为抗议活动还是举行了。现在它其实已经不再是一场抗议了，因为基座上已经没有雕像了。没错，这就像是一个派对。是的，这就像是一场庆祝活动，有点像某种仪式，它主要由这些
activists, the Red Nation, and there were speeches. And then protesters pushed through the gate and actually climbed up on the pedestal where the statue had been before. And there was, you know, dancing and drumming and singing. Activists dipping their hands in red paint and putting those handprints all over the pedestal that had held that horse and Oñate until that morning. This is an act of decolonization! And this is an act of liberation! So that brings us to the other Oñate monument in Albuquerque. So the same day that Oñate statue came down in Alcalde, there was this protest at the statue in Albuquerque.
活动家、“红色国家”组织发起，并且有演讲。然后抗议者冲过大门，实际上爬上了之前放置雕像的基座。你知道，有舞蹈、击鼓和唱歌。活动家用红色的颜料沾湿双手，把这些手印到处印在直到那天早上还支撑着那匹马和奥纳特的基座上。这是去殖民化的一幕！这是争取解放的一幕！这就把我们带到了阿尔伯克基的另一座奥纳特纪念碑。所以在阿尔卡德的那座奥纳特雕像倒塌的同一天，阿尔伯克基的那个雕像处也发生了抗议活动。
And we heard a little bit about the protest at the beginning of the show. But I want to hear more about what actually unfolded there. So it sounds like a lot of people we heard from your original story, like Tweety Suazo, were actually at that protest. So, tell me about that. Yeah, it was a lot of the same people who opposed it in the 90s had planned this peaceful prayer vigil to happen in the park across the street from the statues. And so, that's the way the protest starts out. It's the early evening, people are sitting on the grass, people are making speeches. Tweety makes a long speech where she's trying to evening. People are sitting on the grass. People are making speeches. Tweedy makes a long speech where she's trying to inform people, telling them about the history
我们在节目开始时听到了关于这场抗议活动的一些情况。但我希望能听到更多关于那里实际发生的事情。听起来我们从你最初的故事中听到的人，比如图迪·苏亚佐，实际上也参加了那场抗议活动。所以，跟我讲讲那里的情况吧。是的，许多在90年代反对它的人都计划在雕像街对面的公园里举行这场和平的祈祷守夜活动。所以，抗议活动就是这样开始的。那是傍晚时分，人们坐在草地上，人们在发表演讲。图迪发表了一场长篇演讲，她试图在傍晚。人们坐在草地上。人们在发表演讲。图迪发表了一场长篇演讲，她试图在向人们通报情况，向他们讲述这座雕像的
of this statue and the history of Oñate. And there's a few hecklers at one point, but primarily it's like a speeches, quiet, peaceful affair. But at the same time, and really picking up after the prayer vigil ends, there's a kind of second protest, mostly younger people, activists who want to clearly take more of a direct action that's happening over at the statue itself. And so, did you get a sense from Tweety how she felt about this transition in the protest style and what this felt like for her? Even just what it felt like just to be there back again after all this time, really. Yeah. I mean, I think there's a certain amount of like, okay, we have to inform people again, but still a kind of like stubborn faith and hope that if people just understand, then they'll be able to call their city counselors.
历史以及奥纳特的历史。一度有几个起哄的人，但主要还是演讲、安静、和平的事务。但与此同时，在祈祷守夜活动结束后真正升温的是，有第二种抗议活动，主要是年轻人、活动家，他们想要明确采取更多的直接行动，这些行动就发生在雕像本身旁边。那么，你从图迪那里感受到她对这种抗议风格的转变有何感受，这对她来说是什么感觉？甚至仅仅是经历这一切之后再次回到那里是什么感觉。是的。我的意思是，我认为在某种程度上，就像是，好吧，我们必须再次告知人们，但仍然有一种顽固的信念和希望，那就是如果人们只是理解了，他们就能够打电话给他们的市议员。
They'll use the levers of democracy the way it's supposed to work. And we can do something about this. But as the prayer vigil ends and she's driving away, she sees that people are now climbing up on the statue. She sees that there are these members of the New Mexico Civil Guard, these mostly white dudes in camo with machine guns. And she was really worried. I'm sitting there thinking, ooh, this doesn't look good. And I'm like, well, I'm glad I'm leaving because I don't want to be here. It was just, no, that's not what we wanted. That's not ever what we wanted. In some ways, she recognizes they have the same goal. She wanted to see that statue taken down, but not the way that they were doing it. So this sort of transition happens, and then a kind of chaos unfolds.
他们会按照民主本该发挥作用的方式来运用民主的杠杆。我们可以对此做些什么。但当祈祷守夜活动结束，她开车离开时，她看到人们现在正爬上雕像。她看到新墨西哥州国民警卫队的这些成员，主要是穿着迷彩服、拿着机枪的白人小伙子。她真的很担心。我坐在那里想，噢，这看起来不太妙。我想，嗯，我很高兴我要离开，因为我不想留在这里。这只是，不，这不是我们想要的。这绝不是我们想要的。在某种程度上，她认识到他们的目标是一样的。她希望看到这座雕像被拆除，但不是以他们那种方式。所以这种转变发生了，随之而来的是某种混乱的局面。
Can you explain a little bit about what happened in terms of the escalation that led to the shooting? So basically, it starts out with people who are climbing on the statue. There's chanting, there's some defacing, there's tying a sign around it. But things seem to escalate when somebody takes a pickaxe and starts chipping at the, I guess it's concrete around Oñate's feet
你能稍微解释一下导致枪击事件的升级发生了什么吗？所以基本上，它始于人们爬上雕像。有口号声，有一些污损，有人在上面系了一个标志。但当有人拿着一把鹤嘴锄开始凿，我猜是奥纳特脚周围的混凝土时，局势似乎升级了
with the idea to actually start removing the statue with physical force. And it's a chaotic scene, and I'm reconstructing this from a lot of videos from different angles, but it turns out what happened is that there's a guy who was pushing protesters down. He gets kind of pushed out of the crowd. He allegedly maces some people. He's chased away. And in these fragments of video, what you see at the very end is he's being chased away from the protest, essentially. And in the chaos, he pulls out a gun and he fires several shots, shooting a protester. So what do we know about the shooter
其目的是通过武力真正开始拆除这座雕像。这是一个混乱的场景，我是从许多不同角度的视频中还原这一幕的，但事实证明发生的事情是，有一个人在推搡抗议者。他被挤出了人群。他据称向一些人喷射了梅斯毒气。他被赶走了。在这些零碎的视频中，你最后看到的是他基本上被赶出了抗议现场。在一片混乱中，他掏出一枪并开了几枪，击中了一名抗议者。那么我们对开枪者了解多少呢？
and the person that got shot after all the smoke cleared and a few days later? What was the story? So the man who's been charged with the shooting is actually a former city council candidate. His name's Stephen Baca. And much as he was carrying a handgun that day, he's been a very outspoken proponent of open carry. I actually found a post on Facebook where he was showing up at a city council meeting to talk about a plastic bag ordinance with his handgun in the city council chambers. And the man who he shot was an artist and a protester named Scott Williams. So Scott Williams is a white guy. I'm a Native American. I spoke with a close friend of his, Autumn Chacon, and they were part of the same community
以及尘埃落定几天后被枪击的那个人？故事是怎样的？因此，被指控犯有枪击罪的人实际上是一名市议会前候选人。他的名字叫斯蒂芬·巴卡。尽管他那天随身携带了一把手枪，但他一直是一个直言不讳的公开携枪支持者。我实际上在Facebook上发现了一篇帖子，他曾带着手枪出现在市议会会议上，讨论关于塑料袋的条例，并进入了市议会会议大厅。而被他枪击的人是一位名叫斯科特·威廉姆斯的艺术家和抗议者。所以斯科特·威廉姆斯是个白人。我是一名美洲原住民。我与他的挚友奥特姆·查孔进行了交谈，他们属于同一个
of activists and artists. The two of them had gone to Standing Rock together. We don't always see eye to eye as far as our backgrounds, our levels of privilege, our access to certain institutions. But fundamentally, we know what's right and wrong, and we've become very close friends. So he's someone who absolutely, in her words, he was a person who was very intentionally recognizing that as a white person, he could put his body on the line in a way that other people maybe couldn't. And in her view, that's what he did that day. Wow. So there's this awful incident. And just to be clear, Scott Williams, who was shot, he seems to be okay. He's recovering. But meanwhile, what is happening with the statue? Yeah, so they did not have a lot of success with that pickaxe and rope. The statue was still there at the end of the night, but the next morning, kind of similar to what happened in Alcalde, the government decided that in order to avoid further conflict, they would just take it down themselves. So, now you've got all the settlers and a couple Spanish soldiers and then just a little divot in, the original Oñate statue from up north had its foot cut off and there's some activists that had it, have been keeping it hidden, and it shows up. So what was that like? that night. I only realized this later, I think, when I saw the photograph taken by Simone Romero,
活动家和艺术家的社区。他们俩曾一起去过立岩。就我们的背景、特权水平、获得某些机构的渠道而言，我们并不总是意见一致。但从根本上说，我们知道什么是对什么是错，并且我们已经成为了非常亲密的朋友。所以用她的话说，他绝对是一个非常刻意地认识到作为一个白人，他可以以其他人可能无法做到的方式将自己的身体押注在危险之中的人。在她的看法中，这就是他那天所做的事情。哇。所以发生了这起可怕的事件。需要明确的是，中枪的斯科特·威廉姆斯似乎没事。他正在康复中。但与此同时，这座雕像发生了什么？是的，他们用那把鹤嘴锄和绳子并没有取得太大成功。到那天结束时雕像仍然立在那里，但第二天早上，有点类似于在阿尔卡德发生的事情，政府决定为了避免进一步的冲突，他们将自己动手把它拆除。所以，现在你有了所有的定居者和几个西班牙士兵，然后只有一个小坑，来自北方的最初的奥纳特的脚被砍掉了，有一些活动家一直把它藏起来，现在它出现了。那是什么感觉？那天晚上。我想我是在后来看到《纽约时报》记者西蒙·罗梅罗拍摄的照片时才意识到这一点的，那是一个令人惊叹的画面，在泰格斯公园前面，你看到这个黑人把偷来的脚高举过头顶。这是一个，是的，就像是一个不可思议的手势，我后来意识到那个人是民意公共敌对组合的成员布赖恩·哈格罗夫。布赖恩·哈格罗夫，纽约人，音乐家。人们喜欢叫我活动家。大多数人从我效力于公共敌对组合时认识我。这太棒了。他的联系是什么？是的，所以事实证明布赖恩·哈格罗夫搬到了圣达菲，他的妻子和女儿与新墨西哥州的普韦布洛人有直接联系，他妻子的父亲来自泰苏克普韦布洛。但他最近才被卷入其中。他被一些活动家接洽了。他不想透露太多细节。这可能并不令人意外。但作为这只脚的守护者的那些人问他是否愿意参与这场抗议活动。
a New York Times reporter, that was this kind of amazing image where in front of Teguese Park, you saw this black man holding the stolen foot above his head. It was, yeah, just kind of like an incredible gesture, which I would come to realize that that guy was Brian Hardgrove, member of Public Enemy. Brian Hardgrove, New Yorker, musician. People like to call me an activist. Most people know me from my time with Public Enemy. That's amazing. And what is his connection? Yeah, well, so it turns out that Brian Hargrove moved to Santa Fe, and his wife and daughter are directly connected to the Pueblos in New Mexico, his wife's father's from the Tezuque Pueblo. But he kind of just got brought into this fairly recently. He was approached by some activists. He didn't want to give a lot of specifics. This probably won't be a surprise. But the people who are sort of caretakers of the foot asked him if he'd be willing to be part of this protest.
我马上就加入了。我被要求做的一切就是来到老城的公园支持那场集会。对我来说，这是一个绝佳的机会，展现黑人美国人和美洲原住民之间的团结，我们承受不起看不到这种团结的代价。我们必须看到这种团结。而且，你知道，自乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀以来，美国的黑人一直备受关注。但还有其他群体需要“黑人的命也是命”运动取得成功，
I jumped right on it. And all I was asked to do was come down to the park in Old Town to support that rally. And to me, it was a perfect opportunity to show a unity between Black Americans and Native Americans that we can't afford to not see that. We have to see that unity. And, you know, Black people in America have been getting the focus since this murder of George Floyd. But there are other groups that need the Black Lives Matter movement to succeed
因为他们的声音没有被听到，他们需要我们的运动取得成功，从而也为他们带来更好的机会。因此，他和一大批其他活动家在全国各地发生的抗议活动、“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动与新墨西哥州当地发生的事情之间建立起了这种明确的联系。看到这种联合真是了不起。是的，我想说我交谈过的每个人都看到了这一点。他们将这些抗议活动视为“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动的延伸。瑞安绝对认为它们有着深刻的联系，它们都聚焦于相同的基本潜在问题。它们都是受压迫人民被迫接受持续压迫的同一个问题。
because they're not being heard from and they need our movement to succeed to give them a better shot too. So he and a bunch of other activists are making this explicit connection between the protests happening across the country, the Black Lives Matter protests, and then also what's happening locally in New Mexico. That's really remarkable to see that union. Yeah, and I would say everyone I talk to sees this. They saw these protests as an extension of the Black Lives Matter protests. Ryan definitely saw them as deeply connected, as focusing on the same basic underlying issues. They're the same issue of an oppressed people being forced to accept a continued oppression.
所以布赖恩，他谈到他是如何出现在抗议现场的，当那里还只是祈祷守夜活动时，他悄悄地观察着局势。然后不知在哪个时刻，在合适的时机，有人把这只脚从车里拿出来，为他精心策划了这样一个时刻：他可以把它拿起来，在人群面前高高举过头顶——不是在整个人群面前，而是在至少几个重要的旁观者和能够抓拍照片的人面前。布赖恩描述了当时把那只脚举过头顶是什么感觉。我的感受是，我20岁时就在参加这些抗议活动了。现在我19岁的女儿也在参加。这太荒谬了。这就是我的感受，她现在不得不做这件事。我意识到当我不得不做这件事时，我的父母是什么感受。所以当我举着它时，我的脑海里掠过了这个想法。
And so Brian, he talked about how he showed up at the protest, kind of quietly scoping things out when it was still just the prayer vigil. And then at some point, at the right moment, someone gets the foot out of the car and sort of orchestrates this moment for him where he can take it up and just hold it over his head in front of not the whole crowd, but at least a few significant onlookers and someone who could snap a photo. And Brian described just what it was like to hold that foot above his head in that moment. What I felt, I was doing these protests at 20 years old. Now my daughter is doing it at 19. And this is absurd. That's what I felt, that she has to do this now. And I realized what my parents felt when I had to do it. So that crossed my mind as I was holding it.
就像是，这一切什么时候才会结束？这就是所有这些抗议活动所提出的问题，即这一切什么时候才会结束，这场相同的斗争是否会一代又一代地传递下去？这个国家从来没有用简单的方式做事。它总是用困难的方式做事。所以现在它必须同时处理多个问题，而它本可以在时机成熟时解决其中每一个问题。
It's like, when's this going to end? That's the question, right, for all of these protests, is when's it going to end, and is this same fight going to keep being handed down from one generation to the next? And this country has never done things the easy way. It's always done things the difficult way. And so now it's got to deal with multiple issues at once when it could have dealt with each one of them when the time was right.
尽管它们同时存在，因为这个国家是建立在现在正在抗议的人们的鲜血之上的。但我们已经经历了几个世纪来处理这个问题，而我们从来没有有效地解决过它，其程度仅仅取决于这个国家的舒适度。现在这个国家被迫面对现实。在阿尔伯克基，在新墨西哥州，我的意思是，这种清算真的才刚刚开始。不仅在雕像方面——虽然这也是其中之一，他们已经在圣达菲推翻了迭戈·德·巴尔加斯雕像。还有人讨论可能会拆除其他纪念碑。但对于活动家，特别是那种更年轻的活动家群体来说，他们认为这比
Although they all existed at the same time because this country was built through blood of the people that are now protesting. But we've had a couple of centuries to deal with, and we've never dealt with it effectively, only to the degree of the nation's comfort. Now the country is forced to reckon. And in Albuquerque, in New Mexico, I mean, that reckoning is really just beginning. Not only as far as statues, though that too, they've already brought down the Diego de Vargas statue in Santa Fe. There's talk of other monuments that might come down. But for the activists, particularly that kind of younger group of activists, they see this as so much
雕像要宏大得多。当我与奥特姆·查孔交谈时，你知道，我问拆除雕像是否算是一次成功。而这并不是她所追求的。她想要，比如迫使各种机构——阿尔伯克基博物馆、阿尔伯克基市、阿尔伯克基警察局——真正深入地质疑并根除他们自身的系统性种族主义。所以我们希望阿尔克里克市的所有公民机构，我的意思是，在整个国家范围内，
bigger than statues. When I was talking to Autumn Chacon, you know, I asked if taking down the statue was a success. And that's not what she's after. She wants to, like, force the institutions, the Albuquerque Museum, the city of Albuquerque, the Albuquerque Police Department, to really deeply question and root out their own systemic racism. So we would like all civic institutions in the city of Elk Creek, I mean, throughout the nation,
在全世界范围内，但首先从市内开始，看看它们是如何存在结构性缺陷的，这些缺陷直接导致了有色人种内部的经济和健康差距，存在着令有色人种难以在那里找到工作、受到平等对待、获得公平报酬的制度性缺陷。我的意思是，这很复杂，我们追求的是真正的问责，而不是创可贴式的解决方案。追求的是真正的问责，而不是创可贴式的解决方案。所以奥纳特可能已经消失了，但从这些活动家的角度来看，他们并没有赢得这场战斗。
throughout the world, but for a start within the city to look at how they have structural flaws that directly cause economic health disparities within people of color, that there are institutional flaws that make it hard for people of color to get a job there, to be treated as equal, to be paid fairly. I mean, this is complex, and we're seeking actual accountability rather than band-aid solutions. seeking actual accountability rather than band-aid solutions. So Oñate may be gone, but from the perspective of these activists, like they have not won the battle.
这只是微不足道的最初一步。是的。说到最初一步，布赖恩手里还有那只脚吗？所以布赖恩，他手里已经没有那只脚了。事实上，他说他甚至不知道它在哪里。我完全不知道。它不在我手里，我甚至不知道谁拿着它，所以我完全不知道。这是我能给你的最好答案。
This is just the tiniest first step. Yeah. Speaking of first steps, does Brian still have the foot? So Brian, he does not still have the foot. In fact, he says he does not even know where it is. I have no idea. It's not in my possession, and I don't even know the person who has it, so I have no idea. That's the best answer I can give you.
我完全不知道。也许他们会打电话让我拿着它出现在其他地方，我不知道。但如果发生那种情况，我会给你打电话。如果发生那种情况，我会给你打电话。《99%隐形》本周由斯坦·阿尔科恩制作，德兰尼·霍尔剪辑。混音和技术制作由布赖森·巴恩斯和谢里夫·优素福完成。音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人。
I have no idea. Maybe they'll call me to show up with it somewhere else, I don't know. But if that happens, I'll call you. If that happens, I'll call you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Stan Alcorn and edited by Delaney Hall. Mix and tech production by Bryson Barnes and Sharif Yusuf. Music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is our senior producer.
库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·利、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·伯鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·伯鲁贝、索菲亚·克洛茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。斯坦合作的调查播客《揭秘》（Reveal）推出了一项雄心勃勃的新项目。这是一个名为《美国康复》（American Rehab）的八部分系列节目。该系列追踪了一种广泛使用的戒毒形式的历史，该形式声称通过让人们无偿劳动的方让他们戒毒，包括埃克森美孚和沃尔玛等大公司。《揭秘》将这种模式的根源追溯到一个名为“锡纳安”（Synanon）的危险邪教。在全国阿片类药物危机的背景下，《美国康复》揭露了数万名人们是如何落入这个戒毒机器的齿轮中的。立即订阅《揭秘》，随时随地收听《美国康复》。
Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Berube, Sophia Klatsker, and me, Roman Mars. Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Berube, Sophia Klotzker, and me, Roman Mars. The investigative podcast that Stan works with, Reveal, is out with an ambitious new project. It's an eight-part series called American Rehab. The series traces the history of a widely used form of drug rehab that claims to cure people by putting them to work for no pay, including at big corporations like Exxon and Walmart. Reveal traces the roots of this model to a dangerous cult called Synanon. In the midst of the country's opioid crisis, American Rehab uncovers how tens of thousands of people are caught in the gears of this rehab machine. Listen to American Rehab now by subscribing to Reveal wherever you get your podcasts.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在“无线电街”（Radio Row）制作，该节目目前在北美大陆的多个地点发行，但在我们心中，它永远在加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心。我们是 PRX 旗下“无线电乌托邦”（Radiotopia）的骄傲成员，这是一个由
We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple locations across the North American continent, but in our hearts, it will always be in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radiotopia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
世界上最具创新性、由听众支持、100% 艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问 Radiotopia.fm 寻找并支持我们。就像这些优秀的人们所做的那样：来自西雅图的内特、尼古拉斯·海德、雨果·洛塔斯、凯特·萨维尔和 HiHoHi。谢谢大家。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，或在 99pi.org 上关注本节目。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。但我们在网上的真正家园是 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find us and support us all at Radiotopia.fm. Just like these fine people did, Nate from Seattle, Nicholas Head, Hugo Lotus, Kate Saville, and HiHoHi. Thank you, everyone. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99pi.org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But our true home on the web is 99pi.org. Radiotopia from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
测试